have you ever wondered what ghosts sound
like in the early 1980s vic tandy was
working at warwick labs in the uk where
he designed medical equipment there were
rumors among the staff that the building
was haunted but tandy figured this was
related to the constant sound of life
support systems that were operating on
site but one night tandy was working
late when he started to feel strange the
hairs on the back of his neck stood up
he broke into a cold sweat and felt the
sense of dread wash over him his heart
started to race and he had the very
specific feeling that he was being
watched then out of the corner of his
eye he caught the glimpse of a gray
figure drifting across the room he
turned around the figure was gone
absolutely terrified vic tandy bolted
from the lab and raced home now after he
calmed down he vowed to find a logical
scientific explanation for what happened
well did he
well
[Music]
vic tandy got to his office the next day
and started looking around for the ghost
but he didn't find one but he had
noticed something strange he was an avid
fencer and in his lab he had a foil
locked in a vice wait he sold stolen
merchandise no that's a fence fencing is
a style of sword fighting using a foil a
sword made out of foil no a foil is the
type of sword i'm so confused
it doesn't matter anyway a foil
was locked in a vice and tandy noticed
it was vibrating really quickly even
though nothing was touching it now it
turns out a fan was recently installed
in the lab and was causing a sound wave
to bounce between the walls and the
wave's intensity was focused in the
center of the room which was the
location of the foil
and where he was standing when he saw
the ghost a candy calculated the
frequency of the sound at about 19 hertz
this frequency is important the range of
human hearing starts at 20 hertz so
tandy's fan wasn't audible it's what's
known as infrasound but just because we
can't hear it doesn't mean it can affect
us all material objects have a natural
resonant frequency if the object is
exposed to a sound wave of this
frequency it'll vibrate in response this
is called sympathetic resonance and you
can test this if you strike a key on a
piano in one room a piano in another
room will resonate that same note this
is also why running your finger around
the rim of a glass at just the right
speed will produce sound
now back to tandy's lab it turns out
that the human eye resonates at about 19
hertz so what appeared to be a ghost was
actually tandy's eye vibrating at the
frequency of the fan since this
frequency has an actual physical effect
on the body the sound was causing a
sense of fear and anxiety to employees
in the area and tandy said that when
they switched off the fan it was like a
huge weight was lifted and these
frequencies don't just affect humans
researchers have discovered that just
before a tiger attacks its roar contains
frequencies at 18 hertz which could
disorient their prey long enough for the
tiger to move in for the kill now just
under 20 hertz has been called the fear
frequency for how it affects mammals and
lots of horror movies have used sounds
at or just above the fear frequency to
make their films even scarier
what happens if we go lower lower than
18 hertz yeah
things get much worse how much worse
uh ever hear the brown note the brown
note
does that mean what i think it means
grab a diaper
[Music]
the brown note is said to occur at
frequencies between five and nine hertz
this is the hypothetical range of sound
that supposedly causes humans to lose
control of their bowels i say
hypothetical because nobody's been able
to actually prove it yet the brown note
was famously busted by adam savage on
mythbusters when he surrounded himself
with giant speakers and had the note
pumped into his body now he didn't feel
so great afterwards but his diaper
stayed clean he actually wore a diaper
yup
i love mythbusters me too but here's the
thing about that experiment air really
isn't a great conductor of sound
especially at low frequencies but when
you're physically connected to the
vibration its effects are much more
intense the united states space program
conducted tests that transferred brown
note and other frequencies directly to
subjects bodies by vibrating cockpit
chairs now test frequencies range from
0.5 hertz to 40 hertz and power levels
of 160 decibels is that loud well for a
comparison a lawnmower is 90 decibels a
chainsaw is about 130 and a gunshot is
140 so testing people at 160 db even if
you can't technically hear the sound
it's going to get results test subjects
experience nausea hallucinations
difficulty breathing and involuntary
motor functions
nobody officially crapped their pants
but this experiment is probably where
the urban myth came from but you don't
have to be an astronaut to get sick from
sound there's something called wind
turbine syndrome now not everyone but a
little over 20 of people who live near
large wind turbine farms report all
kinds of negative effects and they range
from difficulty concentrating all the
way up to extreme stress and
uncontrollable migraines in one instance
an air traffic controller almost caused
a fatal plane crash because he was
experiencing insomnia caused by living
near a wind farm now there have been
about 20 studies done on wind farms but
they found no link between the turbines
and people getting sick who conducted
these studies
the wind turbine companies
i thought so still it has been proven
that people who live and work near a lot
of noise experience higher levels of
stress and have more cortisol in their
blood than people who live in quiet
environments so if we know sound can be
dangerous
could it be used as a weapon i'm gonna
go with the yes
yep
the most dangerous frequencies to humans
are at about seven hertz this is the
median alpha rhythm of the brain and the
resonant frequency of many of the body's
organs what does all that word salad
mean this means that at high enough
volume these sounds can directly affect
the central nervous system causing panic
convulsions vomiting and with long
enough exposure organ rupture and death
and one of the most well-known inventors
of infrasonic weapons was a russian-born
french scientist named vladimir govrow
now gavrow became interested in sound
research in 1957 when he was asked to
cure an unknown illness that was
affecting people at a research plant in
marseille now gavro tracked the problem
to air conditioning units that were
generating low frequency sound when the
units were turned off the problem
suddenly disappeared so gavro began
experimenting with acoustics to create a
weapon for the french military a big
shock whenever we discover something
dangerous turn it into a weapon
that does seem to be what happens gain a
function
so gavrow developed a few prototypes
which he tested on himself and his team
and according to reports one of the
researchers died instantly and guerrero
wrote his internal organs mashed into an
amorphous jelly by the vibrations
even people at nearby labs were sick for
hours they said every organ in their
body was vibrating hearts lungs stomachs
everything now these weapons used
infrasound which are frequencies below
human hearing but what about frequencies
above human hearing that's called
ultrasound and it's also dangerous there
are two ways that ultrasound damages the
body the first is that sound waves can
actually heat up human cells which
causes all kinds of problems
the other is something called cavitation
when sound waves pass through an object
they rapidly push and pull on that
object this is called compression and
refraction when ultrasound causes human
cells to cavitate it creates bubbles in
the tissue and this is exactly what
happens to divers suffering from
decompression sickness depends
right the bents ultrasound is such an
effective weapon that has been used by
the us navy to repel pirates
so the us has used sonic weapons against
its enemies but have the enemies of the
us
use sonic weapons to attack americans
turns out
they have
a strange illness has been afflicting
american intelligence officers and
diplomats in cuba and it's now known as
havana syndrome this summer the cia
reported that officers were experiencing
symptoms while traveling to india two
u.s officials visiting hanoi suffered
unexplained health incidents and
recently german officials confirmed that
they are investigating an alleged sonic
attack against the u.s embassy in berlin
so what does havana syndrome feel like
well it's described as someone suddenly
experiencing a broad range of symptoms
like migraines anxiety dizziness lapses
of memory and cognitive disruption now
some people describe that they feel like
they were hit by a blast wave or a beam
of energy and in some cases the symptoms
were brief but other people experienced
such devastating effects that they
required hospitalization and long-term
care the first cases of havana syndrome
were reported in 2016 when canadian and
american officials arrived in cuba
cia officers stationed at the embassy
there reported feeling fatigue nausea
and pressure headaches and brain scans
showed tissue damage that's normally
seen in people with concussions after
being in a car accident the issue was so
serious that the obama administration
evacuated the embassy what if the cubans
had to say about it oh they had no idea
what could be happening yeah but since
then havana syndrome has been reported
by u.s officials all over the world cuba
china russia colombia uzbekistan even
the united states and last year two
white house staff experienced symptoms
while working at the white house
according to investigators the illness
could be the result of a sonic weapon or
exposure to high-energy microwaves
another study done by the national
academies of science engineering and
medicine said that directed pulsed radio
frequency energy could be responsible
many intelligence officers are quietly
pointing the finger at russia but no
evidence has been made public yet what
did the russians have to say about it oh
they deny any involvement
as of now there's still no official
explanation but the cia and state
department have prioritized getting to
the root cause of havana syndrome oh
they're always trying to get to the root
cause they are do they ever find it
yeah
[Music]
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files if you had fun or
learned anything help us out by liking
commenting or sharing this video only
with your help can we defeat the
algorithm until next time be safe be
kind and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you